ing again I just finishing
Swish Video aboutal correctness resp
Challenge
ored
myes too easy on because I
stedare and of course easier
to
others now and I you can't have all
languages ​​up at some phenomenal
Performance Level you you build up a
basic competence and and  then if I were
to
devote some time to German which I would
love to have the time to
do you know reading on say politics and
accumulating that vocabulary
political correctness what does that mean in
my opinion the B D there is
in our society in Germany
Sweden in Canada there are some
people and these people are this
so-called moralistic or ideological
ideological elite and they believe that these
are professors in
universities these are politicians these
are people who write for for for ze
and so-called
intellectual intelligence yes and they
believe that  They definitely have what is
right, how you should express yourself and
and if you do
n't say something different then
you will immediately
appear as a racist or fascist or or as not acceptable and that is a lot of
pressure and that prevents people  That's what
makes
people who have their own opinion
and they only say it at
home in the kitchen or when they
're with friends and they're
drinking a glass of beer then they say
things that they're afraid to say in
society and  yes, I don't think that
's healthy, I think
we should have the opportunity
to express our opinion
um and
an example for a good
example I was at the end of November
I was in Germany after our trip
that I took a trip with
my  Ms. we were in Italy and
we were in Germany for four days in November in Munich and I
bought this book because this book is
a bestseller in Germany and this
is also a very interesting book because it is it
I learned a lot
learned about German society,
well, I can't say that I agree
with everything he's
written, but he's done a lot of
research, he's very
honest, he's done a lot of work and
he
's worried about the future of his
country  is a good man, that's
not a bad man, that's not a
racist, that's not a Nazi, but immediately
his political party, the Social
Social Democrats,
they immediately said that we're not,
that's not him, I think he's
no longer  A member of the
Social Democratic Party and other
people have also said that it's
bad, you're not allowed to write like that and
he's caused a lot of problems.
I think that's it. You can
write another book and
you can then counteract all of his inventions
So a different opinion so
write or or or say but
why are you allowed to say that as um viende who
make society that
I think is very bad
e.g. I read in a newspaper
in Germany that he said that
all Jews
share the same gene  Genin gen
I think and that's so that
's terrible how can that how can you
say that because in Germany the topic of
genetics
uh Jews Germany it doesn't work you
can't put it all
together in one sentence it doesn't work
but there are Jews who  say the same thing
that is not or that is true the
truth or is not the truth
and if it is not the truth
you can
bring out other truths but but is not a
reason to attack this man
and we have the  this
same phenomenon here in Canada I am
against
this so a lot of multiculturalism I
think this is not a good strategy
this is not a good policy for
our country nor is it good for the
immigrants I think it will
be better if the immigrants
integrate we we can  not that
these people are forcing this
but in Canada we have a like this the the the the the
how do you say the politically
correct the politically correct ideal that
should be multiculture multiculturalism
if we are against multiculturalism
then we are Americans or what but
we have just as much assimilation
Assimilation or integration in Canada
as in the USA this is the same
phenomenon we are a melting part
just like in the USA but we have this this
ideal I for me that is not
true that is not true we are we
have in the second third generation
are  we just like in the in the in
the United States but like that
we can't say we have to say
we are
multicultural and if we if I say
I'm against that and I had this
experience I was on a a
reunion and I have  I said I do
n't think that's a good idea then
big racist
that reaction was unbelievable and and I
think this pressure of the people are
not they don't have the permission they
don't they don't feel in
the freedom to express their own opinion
and there are a lot of examples and it
's always the case that we defend the
minorities, okay, so when a
uh Christian
preacher says I'm against those who allow
marriage
uh so those who allow
gay people to get
married I'm against it says
a Protestant pastor oh  You ca
n't say that's bad, but if
an imam or
someone from a so-called
minority culture says that no, that's okay,
that's multiculturalism,
he can say that. We have no idea
what all the people are saying in the mosque,
but that's it  There are a lot of
things against Jews and homosexuals but
it never gets into the
newspapers but when a Christian
pastor says something then it's very strong.
I think we should go to our countries,
we have the right
to defend our majority culture and
uh political  Correctness uh it
creates the danger that we will
uh possibly
lose our our rights in our own country and
and I think Sarosa has mentioned a little bit
about it in his book and uh
I think that we should
have more freedom and less uh political
ktag  and that with all my
mistakes in German is my opinion goodbye